tiens vous savez marcel desailly qu'on
ne bouge pas pendant le génial
c'est bien jugnot bien interview ici
donc je vous ai de parano un peu oui
du fait de ma profession oui un petit
peu vous avez peur que les gens disent
du mal de vous comme ça par derrière
ils ont je prête beaucoup attention à ce
que l'on dise quelquefois trop quoi dire
de masse a résulté de mégalo non dit mme
itto peut-être quelques fois vous êtes
schizo maso peut-être vous aimez bien
qu'on vous fasse mal attention ici du
passé a laissé entendre dimanche ce
maître du splendid
est ce que vous êtes sadow j'aimais
faire mal non vous aimez faire souffrir
non j'avoue ne pas dire aux heures de
tig est ce vous être qu il a du talent
mais
non en fait je veux dire c est ce que
vous êtes ton monte comme
elle est déçu c'est normal heureusement
dalsa place est déjà très très contente
d'être à côté de lui chaque chose en son
temps je vous êtes homo non que je sache
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos oui
place et je vous ai trio et un et deux
et trois j'avais fait un plaisir non
voilà j'aime essayer même nom marcel
picot
il faut tout essayer marcel mais enfin
il a peur devant la barre transversale
est-ce que plus être exhibo un petit peu
mal à vue et dans le reportage sous les
douches en trois ans qui prime avec ta
mais jacques chirac c'est pour ça je
vous aide pour nous j'ai dû avoir la
période comme tout le monde bancaire
est-ce que vous arriviez de chamallows
chamallows jamais la chance est ce que
vous êtes pétards d'eau non non dans ma
profession c'est d'ailleurs en intro de
contrôler les gardes
est ce que vous êtes adamou je sais je
sais trop bien le voilà
à la longue on soir bonsoir